people have been killed in the capital
heave as a shopping center is hit by
russian shells the mayor announces a
two-day curfew
rescue from the rubble firefighters
managed to pull some people out alive
from the destroyed building
no surrender ukrainians ignore a russian
deadline to give up the besieged city of
mariupol
the windows have been
torn and broken and all they can do now
is just try to repair this damage
and preparing to defend itself we'll
have the latest from odessa as it is
targeted by russian shelling for the
first time
and also this hour nazarene zagari
ratliff speaks publicly for the first
time since her release from an iranian
prison hitting out at the length of time
it took for her to be freed
what's happened now should have happened
six years ago i shouldn't have been in
prison for six years
[Music]
well hello good afternoon you're
watching a special programme on the war
in ukraine live from la viv we'll have
all the latest from ukraine shortly but
before that to breaking news from the
last hour
well nazanin zagari ratcliffe has been
speaking publicly for the first time
since her release from a prison in iran
in a news conference in westminster
nazalene spoke of her happiness at being
reunited with her family but she also
questioned why it had taken five foreign
secretaries and six years to secure her
release
i believe that the meaning of freedom is
never going to be complete until such
time that
um all of us who are unjustly um you
know detained in iran are reunited with
our families
to begin with murads but also
the other dual nationals
you know members of the um
like religious groups or prisoners of
conscience who are i mean we do realize
that if i have been in prison for six
years there are so many other people we
don't know their names who have been you
know suffering in prison in iran so i i
think
the justice in iran does not
have any meaning because in worst case
scenario you are you know being given
um
um the the unfair trial if you're lucky
then you'll be picked up by
by a kind of semi-fair judge but in most
cases you're not being lucky um
the journey back home was tough i ran
what richard said to thank the
uh
foreign secretary i have i do not really
agree with him on that level
i'm gonna tell you that because i have
seen five foreign secretaries changed
over the course of six years that is
unprecedented given the politics of the
uk i love you richard respect whatever
you believe but i was told many many
times that oh
we're going to get you home that never
happened so there was a time that i felt
like do you know what i'm like no i'm
not even going to trust you because i've
been told many many times that i'm going
to be taken home but that never happened
i mean how many foreign secretaries does
it take for someone to come out five
it should have been one of them
eventually so
now here we are what's happened now
should have happened six years ago
i think
we all know
this is i'm assuming this is going to be
public knowledge how i came home
i'm not going to mention i don't know
the details but what took me home now
on the very same day 17th of march 2022
that is the very same day that i left
london 17th of march 2016 to go on a
two-week holiday and i never returned
on the flight that i was coming back
home with but i think it should have
happened exactly six years ago i
shouldn't have been in prison for six
years
and
and yeah i think
i think
we have we have gone through a lot it
has been a tough journey
um
the coming back was also very tough
so you you do realize that you know
coming back to a daughter who is
nearly eight
i left her when she was not even two
there was a whole lot to catch up
but richard um and gabrielle and getting
to know them better
well let's get reaction to that then our
correspondent iva bennett was there in
westminster and you got the sense of
emotion in the room didn't you either
yeah absolutely a lot of emotion on
display from everyone there and um it
was a fascinating press conference
nearly an hour long and i was struck by
two things um firstly how
humble dignified and sharp naznin was
despite everything she's been through
she's only just got home in the early
hours of thursday morning after being
held in iran for nearly six years her
and her husband richard paid tribute to
all of those who helped secure her
release she also
said how excited she is to be a family
again and when asked what was the
specific memory
that she held onto that kept her going
all these years she described a visible
memory that was her daughter gabriella
who's now seven
who was a toddler when she left playing
and richard has been getting a cup of um
getting her a cup of fennel tea
but she also said how tough it is going
to be readjusting to life at home she
left
of course when gabriella their daughter
was just about to turn two she's now
just about to turn eight so a lot of
readjusting to do the other thing that
that struck me was the level of anger on
display uh from naznen and and everyone
else at that table um
she said uh in reference to her release
this should have happened six years ago
that was a thinly veiled reference to
the
long-standing debt to iran that the uk
government paid of 400 million pounds
that helped secure her release it was
something that the government has
repeatedly said over the last six years
that is not uh
attached to her release but she's in no
doubt that it was saying this should
have happened several years six years
ago how many foreign secretaries does it
take so i think there will be
ramifications to come for the government
on that tulip city calling for a review
by the foreign
affairs select committee but for now the
focus is on uh this family being whole
again
either thank you very much indeed well
let's take you straight to our political
editor beth rigby who's uh with one of
those mps who worked so hard to get
nana's nazanin free beth
hi anna yes we've just come out of that
press conference and it was absolutely
incredible
i have to say to see nazdin uh in the
flesh looking so well so articulate and
i'm with the woman who has campaigned
tirelessly alongside richard ratcliffe
to get nazanin home it's tulip sadiq uh
nazanin's mp tulip how how was that you
were tearing up in there i saw it how
was that for you it was very emotional
but it was even more emotional when i
met nazineen for the first time
yesterday so i met her in west hampstead
and it was quite strange because i know
so much about her life and she knows so
much about my life and i know details
about her medical health that most
people wouldn't know and yet i'd never
met this lady and when we saw each other
she just embraced me
so so hard and it was just i sort of
felt like are we doing this so that we
can feel that we're actually here in
real life and so she helped me for quite
a long time and she did thank me quite a
lot and i said to her it was all your
husband and she laughed and she said
i've been hearing this a lot and you saw
how sweet they were with each other in
the press conference as well then all
she could talk about is
being with gabriella asking me about the
community around there the school that
gabriella goes because i know the school
well she was asking me about that it was
all questions about our family was
nothing about government are you an mp
what do you do like i don't think she's
met many mps before but it was not about
that it was just about local issues and
life
and tulip you haven't met her but you
must feel like you know her what was
your impression of her
when you met her was she how you
imagined her to be what surprised you
about her or was she exactly how you
thought she might be she was a lot more
composed and articulate and calm than i
would have been if i had been locked
away for six years if that makes sense i
expected her to be
a lot more jittery and worried but
actually she was just so calm and
quite motherly i'd say and just
generally very dignified quite softly
spoken like richard
but also was making quite a few jokes
which i was laughing at because we
talked about the hunger strike and i
said you know richard lost 12 kilos and
she said yes i think he's gained 11 of
those back again
which i just thought was so funny but
you can see the chemistry between them
and you can see how gabriella is so
happy to be back with her parents but no
there was definitely an element of how
are you standing up and looking so
articulate after what you've gone
through and the trauma you've got
through but it also brings home just
meeting her beth you've met her today
the unfairness of the whole situation
that this innocent woman a mother of a
wife a daughter she was locked away
she's lost six years of her life
because she was a pawn caught between
two countries i mean i feel outraged and
it was interesting and this i have to
throw back but it was interesting
because richard sort of thanked the
foreign secretary for getting her out
and nazney says i'm going to have to
disagree with you on that and you in
that press conference talked about how
many uh foreign secretaries prime
ministers people that denied the link
between her imprisonment and the debt
and i asked her about that too and she
said there was a black hole in her heart
but she left it on the plane there has
to be some anger there doesn't there but
a bit of anger but also you want action
don't you so it's a moment of reflection
i think for the whole family and i
understand why with some of the
questions she said i'd rather not answer
that and i'll come back to you she did
talk about the black hole but i i think
genuinely she wants time to reflect
process and then i think the angle will
probably come to be honest because as
you say she was a bit more reticent
about thanking the foreign secretary
because she's dealt with so many and she
knew that there was the works had been
in progress for a while there'd been so
many false dawns
what i want to say beth though is for me
the chapter is closed in terms of my
constituent is home that's fine but i
owe it to nasalin
to look into why it took so long she
said to me the minute the debt was paid
she was home they were just pushing her
out of the door and you heard in the
conference she talks about how she was
told from the second week of her
imprisonment that she would be home if
we paid the debt so my question is why
didn't we pay the debt earlier what were
the restrictions in place was there a
lack of will are there some other
questions we should be exploring and
that's why i've said i've looked into a
review and i've also chair of the
foreign affairs select committee to look
into an inquiry of how nazdin's case was
handled like for a start
in 2013 there were three iranian
officials who came to this country to
negotiate the payment of the dead what
happens there and then what happened to
the deal last year which i by the way i
did raise that in prime minister's
questions and and the prime minister
gave me a sort of half answer but i
still want to know because they might be
thinking well she came home now this
deal was only last year a whole year is
a very long time in a person's life to
be a young child exactly and the time
passes and today i've been observing
and gabriella you know i'm quite
interested having had a child i have a
child of similar age and you can
definitely see that when she mentions a
friend lazine will say oh who's that
friend again oh yeah i saw a picture but
i haven't met her i mean how would you
feel if you didn't know your child's
best friend i mean i know every detail
of my child's best friend so i think we
need an inquiry we need a review we need
to look into this but we also needed to
look at the wider issue of this um
taking hostages you know taking hostages
in iran and then asking us for money or
whatever reason there's got to be some
answers and i don't feel the case is
closed until we have that review so i'll
certainly be pushing for it all right
tulip thanks so much thanks thanks for
joining us uh a moment of celebration
over the weekend uh some moments there
in that press conference though with
questions that need answering richard
radcliffe told me last thursday that
there were lessons to be learnt
nazanin there certainly has questions
for the government and the mp chulip
sadiq now call in for an inquiry by the
foreign affairs select committee but
above all of that wasn't it wonderful
to see nazanin i can tell you gabriella
was at the front uh playing on a phone
for most of the time like any uh normal
seven-year-old
yeah lovely to have some good news beth
rigby thank you very much indeed with
that breaking news of course that we
heard from nazanin for the first time
let's return then to our coverage of the
war in ukraine i'm in uh lev here in uh
western ukraine we're at a library in
the city repurposed for the war effort
with volunteers as you can see
fabricating camouflage for ukrainian
soldiers it is day 26 now when attempts
by the invading forces to break a
perceived stalemate are hitting
civilians hard overnight ukrainians in
the crucial southern port of mariupol
refused to bow to russian demands that
they surrender the city
further west another strategic port
odessa was directly targeted by putin
for the first time and last night in the
capital at least eight people were
killed after shells landed on a shopping
center
so our special correspondent alex
crawford has this report now from the
stricken district of kiev
amidst all the rubble of the latest
russian strike on the capital fire crews
pull out a survivor
his hands grip his rescuers as he's
carefully lifted to safety
this is what life is like for those
living in the city right now
an attack can come out of nowhere
anytime anyplace
this explosion was substantial
and captured on the car park cctv
it was one of several bombs to hit the
capital city overnight
but shortly afterwards photographs began
circulating on the internet which
appeared to show the shopping mall with
military vehicles parked underneath it's
not clear how recent these photographs
are or their origin
but british intelligence reports suggest
the russian military is intensifying its
attacks on key
the capital is still thought to be
russia's key military objective and
defence officials are warning the troops
will prioritize attempts to encircle the
city over the next few days and weeks
there's still fierce fighting to the
north of here but while russian troops
have stalled in their advance on the
capital they're using long-range rocket
strikes instead to terrorize and kill
what are they trying to achieve by
mercilessly bombing shopping malls
hospitals maternity areas houses
civilians this military chaplain says
what do they want to achieve
i can't understand it he says
do you understand it he asks us i don't
think you
can the attacks are causing terrible
destruction and spreading fear
i don't feel safe anywhere in ukraine
she tells us
the city authorities have turned the
capital into a fortress and the russian
troops have been mostly held at around
20 kilometers away around the perimeter
in the center they are resolutely trying
to continue something resembling
normality here
although the sudden spike in attacks has
led to a second 35-hour curfew being
imposed within a week starting tonight
and the russian military showing they
can instill terror and kill with these
indiscriminate attacks without setting
foot inside the capital
alex crawford sky news keeve
[Music]
well let's take a look then at some of
the other key developments of the day
the u.s president joe biden will travel
to brussels to meet nato allies and g7
leaders to discuss the coordinated
response to russia
an ammonia leak at a chemical plant in
the eastern ukrainian city of sumi has
now been contained but the cause is
still unknown
as of yesterday 3.4 million refugees
have now fled the country according to
the un refugee agency
well outside kiev attention is falling
again on mario poll today overnight
authorities there ignored a russian
deadline to surrender that crucial port
city tens of thousands of civilians also
remain they rejected the offer of
humanitarian corridors over fears of
being shelled on the way out or being
forcibly deported to russia let's speak
now to our correspondent sally lockwood
who's also here in la viv and i guess
there was no way that they would uh
listen to that surrender terms put
forward by the russians sally
yeah that's right anna that offer of a
ceasefire from russia had a deadline for
a response from ukraine in the early
hours of this morning and uh the offer
was flatly refused
and rejected long before that deadline
from ukraine of course that offer for
ukrainian forces in mariopol to lay down
their arms
and raise white flags to allow the safe
passage of
more than 300 well tens of thousands of
people that remain trapped in mario paul
there's more than 300 000 estimated to
be there it's not estimated to still be
there it's not clear how many would have
would have got out during this uh
ceasefire today but of course it hasn't
happened it was rejected by the
ukrainian government and also by the
mayor of the city of mario poll why well
because there's simply no trust in
russian forces and what they would do
during this
supposed ceasefire to allow safe passage
for civilians
to leave and that's of course because
there's been nightly bombing of this
city for more than three weeks now
shelters have been bombed uh which have
been housing uh civilians uh the elderly
children it's not clear if those
shelters have become targets but
certainly that is something
that people there fear and it's not just
the nightly bombings anna the city has
also been blockaded medical supplies
food supplies can't get in people there
now even if they survive these bombings
fear that they could be being starved
out
by the russians and of course there's
also a massive
shortage of information going into mario
paul and also coming out now we've
learned today that the last two
journalists still working and reporting
out of mario poll have been extracted by
ukrainian forces having learned that
they were on a russian hit list so it's
going to be even tougher for us to learn
about exactly what is going on inside
that city which is of course such a
focus
by russian forces
why well because if they were to take
mario pole it would allow russian forces
in the east of ukraine and also in the
south to essentially join up
and work in a more
coordinated way together and and give
them more firepower
but i should say that we are we are
learning
some detail uh online and through
relatives
uh who are
trying to get information about their
loved ones who are who are stranded in
mario poll one online group now has 86
000
of loved ones trying to find out
information about where their loved ones
are inside uh mario paul and of course
the biggest concern about this lack of
information isn't just the panic and
chaos that it's causing but it's also
the russia can potentially now with no
journalist journalistic presence in uh
mario paul no power no internet no phone
signal uh can essentially carry out
atrocities with impunity
sally updating us there thank you very
much indeed so let's take a look then on
a map at those developments
you can see why mario paul is so
important it sits between russian
military bases in crimea and the
separatist held region in the east
linking up would allow russian forces to
unite so the city has been surrounded as
you heard from sally there since the
early days of the invasion
well with civilian locations
consistently targeted an art school the
latest thought to be sheltering some 400
people that happened over the weekend
tens of thousands remain there trapped
in desperate conditions
some residents did manage to escape last
week west along a humanitarian corridor
but aid convoys into the city have been
blocked by russia
and as we heard the number of people
killed during an attack on a shopping
center in the portal district of the
capital kiev has risen to eight now
according to latest reports
what another strategic port city firmly
in putin cites is that of odessa laying
further west along the coast from crimea
odessa residents are preparing for a
russian advance weskeisnick martin has
the latest from there where explosions
were heard in the early hours of this
morning
we're at an apartment complex just to
the south of odessa right on the the
coast here and in the early hours of
this morning the residents heard a
series of loud bangs seem to be coming
from the sea and we know that there has
been a russian naval buildup in the
black sea over the past week but shell
started to land here just look at this
impact on the road here with one of the
shells
exploded and when shells hit and make an
impact they're designed to break up into
thousands of pieces of shrapnel and the
effect is pretty obvious to see here on
this building the glass shattered and if
you look closely on the masonry it's
peppered with holes and that is where
the shrapnel flung towards this building
and that is what does the damage with
shells and this morning the residents
here have been trying to pick through
this mess glass just cascaded down from
the building onto the floor here and
they've been trying their best to sweep
it up and i'm they all look pretty
shocked i have to say when you walk
around talking to them and it's pretty
sobering is it when you see the holes in
the ground and the impact that these
shells made and they've been trying to
pull the panes of glass down you know
people living here this is their homes
and you can imagine in the early hours
of this morning a huge explosion a
series of explosions we understand uh
just rocking this place and it's just a
bit further around the corner i've
counted possibly three more impacts
where you've seen similar damage where
the shells have just exploded and
everything in their wake has been has
been shattered now thankfully at this
stage we don't think anyone has been
injured or killed but you know it takes
time for this kind of thing to to come
through and they're going to go through
the apartments and just check that
everyone's okay i was speaking to a
couple just down from here i can't
really show you because of the big
building blocking the sea but they had a
holiday home and a little awning and
that was just completely destroyed by
another shell impact and the military
are here taking pictures an ambulance
turned up i presume just in case anyone
was injured but this damage this whole
of this front of this building if you
look up at it
you can see
the impact you can see the glass the
windows have been
torn and broken and all they can do now
is just try to repair this damage but
you know for some people where the front
has been completely smashed it's hard to
see
them being able to stay here now odessa
in the south here key port city has been
pretty much on standby for the last two
weeks that we've been here anyway and
we've been seeing the naval warships on
the horizon and it's it's possible now
that they are starting to
send shells in
and this is the result
well as the war was on tactics from
russian-backed separatists are becoming
increasingly macabre this weekend they
boasted their use of devastating
so-called vacuum bombs the city of
kharkiv just a short drive from the
border with russia bears the scars of
that vicious fighting but also signs of
a stalemate a correspondent john sparks
traveled with the ukrainian military to
the front line on the outskirts of
kharkiv and a warning his report does
contain images of dead russian soldiers
the most desirable homes in the city of
harkev are located within its northern
suburbs
but no one comes here now
unless you man a checkpoint
or carry a weapon
or drive a t-72 tank
on the outskirts of the country's second
largest city the ukrainians and the
russians take pot shots in the woods
as the ukrainian army awaits the enemy's
next move
we're still inside the city
but it's a war zone it's a battlefield
tanks and heavy armaments
just about everywhere
we were given access to this suburban
frontier and taken to a children's camp
in the trees
with mock turrets and cabins and areas
to play
shells have pierced the grounds and a
rocket hit the door
our guide did not want to show his face
it's actually punctured the door around
here the rocket
inserted itself through the metal frame
nearby we found a soldier called doc
he'd been planting land mines when the
shells came in what did you see what did
you experience
a few minutes later we had to use his
shelter
grad rockets incoming
the signs of war are all around with the
remnants of a russian column littering
the trees
it's a sign of what the ukrainian army
is able to achieve
in the suburbs of harkev the russian
advance has ground to a halt
and in a gruesome display of grit and
intent we were taken to see the bodies
of five dead russian servicemen
a ukrainian captain claiming the
russians have refused to repatriate the
bodies
the battle may have stalled but it
certainly isn't over
everyone in this city is sure of that
so they prepare themselves for the
seemingly inevitable regardless of the
personal cost
john sparks sky news in harkev
well odessa to mario paul kiev to
kharkiv let's get the latest military
analysis then from sky's will frost who
is joined by military analyst air vice
marshal sean bell wealth
thank you so much uh yes sean is uh with
me here and sean we decided to start our
focus in the south east of ukraine today
and into the end of the fourth week of
this war it seems that mario paul is
still bearing the brunt of the russian
attacks just remind us stepping back why
mario paul's such a key target for
president putin yeah thanks wolf i think
part of it you have to go back a couple
hundred years to see that russia owned
all of this uh border area or this
coastline 200 years ago and if you
subscribe to the view that putin still
hails back to the days of the of the
russian empire then taking back this
land is really important
more tactically it's also important
because he's trying to link up crimea to
russia and of course at the moment mario
paul sits right in the middle of that
and therefore
that resistance has to be quashed to
join that link and if you look west to
odessa clearly there's a thousand miles
of resupply so that's probably going to
be a maritime operation rather than a
land operation and we'll see if odessa
is the next target we'll come to that in
a moment but first of all
let's just dive in to mario pole
specifically and of course this is a a
city of just i say an inverted commerce
population 400 000 or so before uh war
broke out at least why is it taking so
long for russia to seize it and what
does seizing a city like this actually
look like
well we're trapped into urban warfare
and as you say it's it's incredibly
difficult i think it makes a mockery of
what putin has been telling his domestic
audience that he doesn't bomb cities and
he doesn't bomb uh populations because
evidently from the pictures that's
exactly what he's doing very ukrainian
are fighting on their home soil they're
fighting for every street every home
every district they're passionate about
it and i think whilst uh the fighting
intensifies it
over here it's evident the morale of the
troops is is suffering and i think this
is probably a good bellwether of
ukrainian resistance across the whole
country ukrainian resistance of course
heavy shelling continues in some of the
latest areas that have been hit whether
by design or accident uh marked there on
that map let's uh take a step back and
look now again at the the whole of
ukraine uh sean and the question now
really
what next if mario paul were to fall
where would be the next era focus of
course we do know from the early reports
in the show that kiev continues to be
bombarded though uh ukrainian forces
resisting fairly well the approaches
from the northeast and the north west
but but where might be next if mario
paul would fall
yeah it's a fascinating question and i
think uh putin holds the answers here i
think from an analyst perspective i
think kiev remains the sort of political
center of gravity and the prize that
pewter would undoubtedly want but given
the fight of mario pole a fraction of
the size i think he might conclude that
that's a bridge too far so i think
there's two
key um clear options for putin one of
which is to take mario paul and then
seek to negotiate from a position of
strength um and therefore avoid having
to fight in kiev but by far the most
dangerous option is if putin decides to
double down it's pretty evident that the
forces he originally deployed into the
region are exhausted they've had a real
kick to morale and they are needing
resupply of fuel arms etc so by doubling
down he'd need to get forces from russia
now if they've either got those reserved
today and if that was true he wouldn't
be calling on mercenaries which is
evident they're trying to do if he
hasn't he's going to have to mobilize
the russian economy he's going to have
to start getting the russian industry
converted do large-scale conscription
and that is a we haven't seen that level
of commitment uh since world war ii and
that would have grave implications for
nato and the west sure thank you so much
that's the latest on day 26
well thank you very much indeed well 3.4
million people have now fled abroad from
this war in ukraine the aim for many of
those fleeing the conflict is to cross
the border they hope to find refuge in a
new life elsewhere but for all of them
it is a harrowing journey so let's bring
in our correspondent mark stone who
joins us now from present michelle in
poland and certainly this is what you're
saying mark isn't it that those who are
arriving now
are some of those who've had really
terrible experiences
just just awful yeah uh we've we've
talked to so many people over the course
of the the past few days people going in
so many different directions as well
many many of them of course leaving
ukraine but but some going back in
having dropped relatives uh outside the
country they now want to to get back in
there get home perhaps in some cases
fight as well let's let's head inside
and show you um the the scene here at
this um small train station which has
become so overwhelmed over the course of
the past few
days and weeks i have to say the good
news today
and we've seen this over the past couple
of days is that there are fewer and
fewer people arriving now um
it's not quite clear why that is we
spoke to the mayor of the town uh
earlier on today he was confused as well
but i i think it's the case that all
those people or most of those people who
are either able to leave physically able
to leave or who want to leave
have now
left although i must say they are still
coming in in waves we saw a train from
odessa
arriving about an hour or so ago uh with
a thousand or so people on board and as
you can see here many many children as
well lots of children uh who are
continuing
to flee such
frightening situations in ukraine from
all over the country they are coming now
we've just got a few updates in terms of
numbers from the um unhcr that says that
1.6 million children are now refugees
outside of the country and
a staggering additional 3.3 million
children are displaced
within ukraine itself so that's almost 5
million children forced to flee their
homes that's one in five of the children
that are in the country let's head
outside to the the other side um and you
can you can have a look at the um
remarkable organization uh that they um
are putting on here with with food
stalls actually some of them have gone
down and and the um you can see the um
sim card there people are offering free
sim cards when people get off the trains
they're greeted by
people with signs uh saying
effectively saying that they can have a
lift to wherever it is they want to go
i've been struck that most people seem
to want to stay in poland
because they hope that very soon they
will be able to get back to ukraine
mark i bet they do thank you very much
mark stone there live on the border in
poland well next up we'll have a view
from kiev in fact i'll be speaking to a
professor who is currently volunteering
there
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
well you join us back in the la viv
region the war may be being fought in
other parts of ukraine that does not
mean the war effort does not take place
here as you can see the volunteers are
hard at work trying to make camouflage
nets it is such a long slow process they
used to make 20
25 of these each day at now it is about
five some of the volunteers would you
believe have decided to go back to work
it's like life almost stopped uh here
but now they're tying each bit on if we
move over it you can see some of the
material that's sent in
old clothes new clothes
materials sent from manufacturers
all has to be the right color at the
moment we're told they're short of mid
brown and dark brown it is of course
winter
and so this is specifically requested by
different battalions uh in the field
they say the dimension they say the
color they say also the
opacity of it as well how transparent it
needs to be but lots of it has been
fleece they can use leggings ladies
tights and so on these are nearly
finished um specific colors as you can
see but through here the earlier stages
they do it on netting
and this is actually an old library
would you believe these are the
bookcases that have been repurposed um
it's a library that closed at the start
of the war but such was the demand for
for books that it decided to reopen on
march the 14th people wanted to come and
and still read they also run a literary
festival here but 30 of the 33 authors
involved in that are currently on the
front lines perhaps they're the people
who will come back with their war
stories and a little bit like the great
war poets of the of the first world war
lots of hard work here if you look
carefully at the material you can see
you know some of the patterns that are
needed and the interesting thing about
this is that if it's handmade
you cannot spot the pattern via a
russian drone
if it is
manufactured they can assess the pattern
and they could see if people are hiding
so if it's handmade as you can see it's
very delicate work
then it means that people can stay
properly hidden
and uh as i said this is all requested
by
specific battalions
what is really important is that people
feel like they are taking part in the
war effort let's go talk to one actually
who himself fled kiev victor i wonder if
i can have a quick word with you i spoke
to you a little bit earlier didn't i i
was just explaining to our audience that
you were you were amongst those people
who decided to leave the capital city
why why did you decide to do that i
decided to do that to take my daughter
out of that city otherwise me and my
wife would have stayed there and we also
did volunteer work like that making
camouflage nets and so on and so forth
but our daughter would not move without
us so we had to go together she was
frightened she was very frightened
because of the explosions because of the
constant air alerts because we had to
sleep in the metro at the metro station
or in the basement
and you've decided to come and volunteer
here you were telling me that you tried
on the first day and it was so popular
there was such a cue it reminded you of
collecting butter in the soviet era
but here you are finally working why is
it important for someone like you to to
volunteer and help the war effort first
of all
this way i i feel not a wasted person
you know because i'm a pensioner now so
i'm doing
maybe a
slight thing a small thing but i'm sure
it's in the right direction maybe it
could save somebody's life and also to
maintain my mental health because here i
i don't feel how the time passes you
know i speak to many wonderful people
like you for example and
also people local people etc etc and
doing this simple
but necessary work it's like passing a
treatment or your psyche and without
swearing because i know you want to what
do you currently feel about what has
happened to your country to ukraine and
and what putin has done effectively to
to many parts of this land
well that was a monstrous thing uh
almost unbelievable that human beings
could do that especially at in this
century it seems like putin and his gang
maybe are stuck in the middle ages
what they are doing here they have
caused
so many grief so many deaths so many
wounded people so many destroyed palaces
that it's incredible i can't believe
that it's happening happening here and
another thing that they can't believe
that russian people support him
because us
have been being so manipulated
using the most
modern techniques of
influence psychic english they believe
him that it's necessary
that's almost incredible victor thank
you very much indeed victor was
explaining to me earlier that many
people here have relatives in russia who
say but it's fine there what are you
talking about we've heard that again and
again haven't we plenty more from here
though after this short break
[Music]
[Music]
independent united kingdom
[Applause]
these last few years have seen some huge
stories
[Music]
and these stories have been driven by
politics by politicians the people in
power
you must stay at home and it's my job to
figure out how these decisions made by
politicians
impact all of us in our everyday lives
this is the worst thing i've ever been
through in my life people turn up here
with their child stuff in a black sack
and just say i don't want to and that is
what it is it's first class poverty is
this an example of the welfare state
failing
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
these are stories that affect us all
millions of children
are now having to catch up
some stories have changed all of our
lives because like the residents the
staff are being infected
politicians they make decisions all of
the time and it's our job to hold them
to account i wonder if you will take
this opportunity to apologize to those
families but in the end the real power
doesn't actually lie with the
politicians
the real power
lies with the people
i'm nick martin i'm the people and
politics correspondent at sky news
[Music]
police have been foreign
southeast asia correspondent in bangkok
[Music]
well ukraine's refugee crisis is not
just one unfolding on its border with
the european union millions of people
have been internally displaced too well
the mayor here in lev has long said this
city has reached its capacity to help
those fleeing the conflict
well the united nations says that in
total 10 million people now have been
displaced whether in or outside this
country situation most acute in mariupol
where some residents are being evacuated
through humanitarian corridors but many
more are fleeing on their own
many headed for odessa from when nick
martin has this report
the buses have been leaving every day
since the war began
this is where families say their
farewells
and the pain of these separations is
written on their faces
the red cross offers safe passage out of
odessa which could be hit at any time
like the other port cities of mariopol
and mikalive
10 million ukrainians have now fled
their homes according to the un
[Applause]
people have been coming here from across
ukraine many of them from cities that
have been attacked from here they head
west crossing the border to a safer
place
i was hugging my mom and trying to hold
back my tears this is julia
she said goodbye to her mum and she has
no idea when they'll be together again
at least she's somewhat safe here
the rest of the family is maripo
honestly we didn't think it's going to
be that bad
we were talking to my grandma
on the 1st of march
it was her birthday
she was born in 1943
so it would be very sad if she didn't
survive this for as well
there's no way that julia can check on
her family in mario paul not now
all she can do is save herself i was
naive enough to think that no one would
ever attack ukraine
because if you have a powerful ally
russian federation
no one would even dare
it feels like a
stop to the back
i hope
people who see this
news coverage
will understand
but ukrainians are not to be blamed
we were just trying to stay
and grow as a nation in our country
we weren't invading anyone else's
country
yes it's political games it's diplomacy
but right now
people's lives are at stake
this is the reality of war
thank you and the toll that it takes on
people nick martin sky news odessa
well among those who have made the
difficult decision to leave everything
behind an escape to safety is alina
tovic the young ukrainian woman has
documented her experience on tick tock
including living in a bunker when the
war started and making her journey to
hungary
well let's uh bring alina in now who has
moved on to madrid you've certainly
crisscrossed europe haven't you elena
but this is such a
tragedy for so many people and such a
personal journey why did you decide to
document it
hello my name is felina and i'm
currently madrid i came here on friday
and
i decided to post videos on tik tok to
show the real situation of war and how
people
feel right now
well tell us a bit about your experience
then you know how long you you stayed
behind where you came from you know what
was the worst bit for you
um i stayed in ukraine for two years for
two weeks
during the war and um one week ago i
left with my mom we took
three trains
and um um
one train took us 30 hours to get to the
hungarian border
and then you've moved obviously to to
spain now you know where will you settle
this is all such sort of short-term
plans that everybody's making you know
what will you do now
um currently we are working on our
documents to stay there like temporarily
protection and
once we get these documents my mom can't
work and i also can study there
and what was it like for you you know
you know effectively living in a bunker
i know that was one of the things that
you documented
um you know how did you get food were
you just there at night was it was it
all the time give us a sense of of how
you've been living
so every day i heard the sounds of
sirens and that means that you need to
go to the shelter or to the basement and
i went to the basement a couple times
but in general i was hiding in the
corridor or in the bathroom because
the basement that i have next to our
house is actually not a very safe place
and the real bomb shelter is
like 10 minutes away from my home so
it's also dangerous to go there at night
so so talk us through some of your your
your um your production for tick tock if
you like what was it that you were
trying to say in those
i wanted to
most of my videos watch foreigners and i
wanted to show how the
um
we lost our freedom that people can
easily go to the supermarket today and
yesterday i talked to my father and he
said that on sunday they couldn't
they were forbidden to go out
because they had curfew
all day long well alina we wish you the
very we wish you the very best of luck
that is alina wallach there um who has
fled and documented her experience on on
tick tock um showing the world like many
people are what life has been like thank
you very much indeed well let's bring in
alexander here who's well i think you're
coordinating all of this aren't you it's
it i can't believe how slow and
painstaking it is to try and make these
nets
um yeah it's now
slower than it was but we still can
produce a decent amount of nets per day
and each time we
finish
that and take it off we're using
national anthem what we are about to do
now you see nearly this one's just about
to be finished but hopefully we can
catch that before the end of the program
how amazed are you that so many people
want to come and volunteer here to do
their bit and you know who are these
made for
i'm not really surprised about
the sheer amount of
people who came here because
each ukrainian
wants to do his part and to do his best
to help
civilians near the frontline to our
soldiers near the front line and they
come here and
trying to be useful yes and the material
i know you told me earlier short of mid
brown and dark brown and you'll change
your color with the seasons won't you so
what are you anticipating
yeah sure
for now unfortunately we shortened dark
brown and mid brown but
i guess in week or two we'll switch to
more greenish
colors and we have plenty of those
well i will let you get on you want to
roll it do you want to sing it and
alexandra thank you very much nedan for
hosting us here today thank you
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
see
[Music]
[Applause]
me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you